[Musique]
pauli plip liste de barmon dévalant
danse dans ce dans les prés
[Musique]
les sentiers sont pleins
ma
on a peur
comme des rois et moi moi toi et tous
l'italie par les sons
[Musique]
saint cyr est un village comme les
autres le matin il paraît toujours
abandonnées les hommes sont touchants
les femmes au travail derrière les
portes fermées et les enfants sont à
l'école sauf pascal et parce qu'elle est
fatiguée de ne rien faire
pascal s'ennuie
les amis ne manquent pas chez lui à la
ferme mais ils ne répondent jamais quand
on leur parle alors que fait courir
oui mais courir tout seul dans les rues
vides de la langue
cela sonne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on pense aux autres à ceux qui
sont en classe tous ensemble tous avec
vincent les grands parce qu'alors rêve
c'est peut-être pour cela qu'aujourd'hui
comme chaque jour pascal va rôder du
côté de l'école comme le chat comme
finette la petite chienne de vincent qui
patiente devant la grille
[Musique]
tu
les nus
[Musique]
que fait-il ce vin à s'enfermer dans la
classe avec les grands du problème
qualité lui qui aime tant courir dans
les bois qui parfois permettre à pascal
de l'accompagner vincent c'est un ami
havrais voilà pourquoi les garçons et
les filles du village le suivent et lui
obéisse à 20 il adopte les chiens perdus
il délivre les bêtes prises au piège
dans les bois et jamais il n'a encore
dit à pascal tu es trop petit mais pour
pascal c'est bien un jour comme les
autres
monsieur l'instituteur ne veut pas de
lui à l'école
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors pascal pour à travers champs tout
droit vers la butte au vent là où
quelqu'un l'app store
[Musique]
ah ah
celui là au moins de leurs angoisses en
laye et pascal peut tout lui raconter ce
que lui dit personne ne le fric le grand
épouvantail de la butte au vent garde le
secret
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m
oh
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est aujourd'hui que pouvoir faire son
annonce demain j'ai dû trop de
représentations le cirque amar à
toulouse les entrées de zone du naufrage
vous verrez également les ai reçus aux
mimiques des singes corolla et tout
houlès l'incomparable share your soul
qui sait tout faire et tout un programme
extraordinaire qui a vu être les grands
comme les petits
et pour finir n'oubliez pas donc ça vaut
avant tout ce jeudi
[Musique]
mais la barrière
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi il est plus que c'est un bon à
rien je vais lui apprendre son métier
jacou de pike
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
restez pas là n'est capable de mort d'un
soldat que défendue tout y est qu'elle
brouille montcoal fois de cheval paris
on est pas mal ici à sacyr ça pourrait
faire du monde de ma représentation
et oui à moins contre paris parce qu'ici
on est pas pourquoi tu es bête pour les
[Musique]
gardiens
les warriors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
vois tu perd rien pour attendre salle p
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
larry
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fu lee voirien pour à quoi s'attendre à
autre chose qu'une poignée de son
[Musique]
moi j'ai pu marquer un pic face tu
t'appelles pollue folie commission
polichinelle
[Musique]
capable de sucre
bakou
[Rires]
ben tu mords pas
petit prix aujourd'hui je peux pas le
gamin de majorer sûrement une idée
[Musique]
pour les oiseaux des foires
les vers du nez
[Musique]
les joies
sur dix ans et jolie keira
on ne va
un jeu
[Musique]
le matin suivant alors que tout de
remettre encore à la ferme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
folie folie
lundi matin pour libye va faire battre
paul il publie police tourne court
maintenant du germinal pas plus grand
que trois souris on craignait aussi
jolie que j'y mettrai des rubans bleus
est bleu et blanc
la nuit lui folie pour la vie elle l'a
relaté les cheveux au vent
jamais je la ferai une petite enfance un
cheval de cire que tous à la tâche et au
bout d'une
mais comme mika salo
lui pas lui pas lu son livre le petit
garçon qui me suivent de la nuit vers
moi je vais
[Musique]
le sol est avec nous et mignot choix
jusqu'au bout
montrer le chemin nous vivons nous si
quelqu'un ne chercher que recherchait le
blé pour partout je suis quelqu'un se
penche sur nous par le vent
mir ali pakistan
dans ce dangereux dans les plaines
j'ai longtemps qu'ils coupent la dette
m
ou les
on est heureux
moi est là
et toujours nous le serons
et palissandre
[Musique]
il est un endroit dans le bois où deux
chemins se croisent à ce qu'elle y
arrive il appelle écoute mais poli ne
répond pas alors pascal prend le chemin
de gauche celui des noisetiers
cette fois il est perdu il ne sait pas
que finat l'a suivi et qu'elle veille de
loin jamais pascal n'a été seul dans les
profondeurs du poil et tous les frais
[Applaudissements]
il
eh oui
fqu
[Musique]
à
je verrai qu'avec toi retrouvera plus
jamais
il
[Musique]
petit calibre
voilà qui n'est pas raisonnable c'est
bien ce que pense lunettes et très vite
elle coud prévenir vincent village c'est
pas possible à paris avait été fermé il
a popularisé le vol on a volé oui mais
qui des voleurs bien approcher les
vallées moi ça m'étonne faut admettre
que ces ports 10 n'est pas d'humeur
bien sûr si la casse et ce alors falloir
qu'on fasse une enquête
un peu ici mi temps mais pas laisser ça
comme ça vient comme quoi les trois fils
aîné avec toi buzz je vais prendre mon
vélo et pourrait manquer je me retourne
et ses cheveux joliment
valère
[Musique]
renseignez partout et frappé à toutes
les portes
il revenait pas les mains vides et c'est
les deux types là bas ils sont chargés
de l'enquète tu entends
pâques est ce que tu m'as regarde c'est
la casse tête de pascal tu piges pas pas
du tout as tu veux dire oui c'est pascal
quatre finales
là pascal ouvert pascal elle sait
quelque chose
écoute silence et discrétion affaire
grave royal et aubry silence et
discrétion si vincent alors les baies du
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais non petit bécasse les choses ça me
connaît surtout une bestiole comme celle
là il m'a mordu il atteint dès qu il a
fait enfin attend un peu espèce de
mioches c'est toi qui a volé le canasson
voilà ce que tu mérites en attendant
pire là je tape en deux temps prendre un
petit et coûte à peu si tu touches à ce
gosse n importe quelle manière
car affaire à moi personnellement oui
est à moi est à moi est à moi est à moi
est à moi est à moi ça va j'ai compris
n'empêche qu'il a volé le cheval il faut
le punir et ramener ce cheval mais s'il
faut ramener le calme et c'est vrai que
tu avais le cheval non c'est seulement
vers la porte
marco polo il aime pas les pressions moi
non plus j'aime pas les prisons alors de
fines et les discours
les gendarmes entendent parler tout ça
on va tous être accusés j'ai su pour
rien moi allez vous mener assez je peux
pas supporter ça et alors la solution
apportée le mon vieux on peut très bien
se débrouiller
écoutez les gants comité a juré de
défendre les fans et les opprimés dit là
toujours d'accord oui bien sûr je suis
d'accord moi aussi j'ai eu raison
d'ouvrir la porte
tout le monde a vu que le forain botha
lisez pas lui le comité doit faire son
devoir
on va voter à main levée qui est pour
garder paul et moi quelques mois
désolé mon vieux la majorité pour pascal
et popoli bombe étant répétez après moi
je jure j'ai caché poli je pense ma
protection et de garder le secret levé
la main droite et déjà dur alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait je pense est politisée
allez on s'en va les gars
[Musique]
car cet appart à manger merci covan
baryton les ficelles tout redevient si
calme tap la fin s'approche et saint
jean qui ce nouveau venu dans le bois
amis ou ennemis bassin aura su que c'est
un peu the language tpe
il sait si bien alors parler il est très
précis ils sont jamais volé leur liberté
[Musique]
allez voir ce qu'ils racontent par tous
les points possibles
il faut leur trouver autant des patrons
recherchait pas trompé oui encore un
allez pouvoir il ya quatre ou deux pays
et puis trouver le vin c'est pas la
peine d'essayer de revenir sans ce bal
d'antan lorsque mois dans deux fosses
m'embêterait patelin et je vous laisse
là alors débrouillez vous on est bien
d'accord
et comptez sur nous on mènera l'inquiète
comme il faut on ira jusqu'au bout
eh bien moi je vous dépêcher à compter
et vous deux vous le retrouvez vous
aurez une bonne récompense c'est vrai
moi je l'aimé bien cette petite mais
c'est pas vrai qu il n'aime pas
[Applaudissements]
attention les voilà
on voudrait tous portant
j'ai plein mon garçon thérapie qui va
manger tous un ennemi qui va au champ
encore de saas ont fait lé là ta maman
sais pas si t'as pas vu un tout petit
cheval de cible au lieu de l'être je ne
sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous dire c'est toi je pense pas le
choix à lui pascal yama recel pour sa
façon et votre fille ce qu'il a on a
rencontré dans la cour il lui a demandé
s'il avait vu de petits fall on n'a pas
eu de ce pas là la ferme cheval du cir
savez bien le circuit et sur la place on
a une idée vous savez père guillaume le
braconnier dans le pays disent que c'est
un drôle de type de bizarre quoi je suis
celui qui nous l'a dit c'est le marchand
de ferraille on dit qu'il a déjà fait de
la prison pour vol ou du ça mais je suis
pas bien sûr que ce soit vrai on va tout
de même allés voir la toiture en parler
aux gendarmes des types comme ça c'est
pour dire mais il vaut mieux se méfier
et oui vaut mieux se méfier aux potters
père guillaume a parlé deux ou trois
collègues qui pose qui fait pas grand
mal vous savez on lui un poids de plus
qu'ils n'en sait enfin à votre bonne
santé pas d'âme
les perfusions il voulait arrêter là
il apporte du cheval et si on lui en
prison à notre place votre cheval ça
m'est bien égal mais le père qu'ils y
ont c'est mon ami faut s'ouvrir une idée
tu as du papier monnaie
merci quelques rayons merci cas la
pierre le super guide est accusé sos
urgences bruneau capitaine
il va porter sa façon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
câble même que la médiature guillaume
est accusé sos urgences bruno qu'est-ce
que samedi ouais c'est akio peut-être
plus vaste et là tu as gardé police
[Musique]
allait bien assagi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
heureusement on arrive à temps
heureusement qu'en cas chez vous on va
vous arrêter les hommes du cirque
ils ont parlé de vous aux gendarmes
pourquoi tu il mériterait les gendarmes
j'ai rien fait moi
bonjour périodes où c'est pas mal passé
par chez vous
oui un stage de cirque a été volé ce
pôle de cirque alors vous n'avez rien vu
non tu viens bon ben oui à +4 amérique
voir la vidéo
alors c'est vous seul êtes en prison
monsieur affaire où un énorme tas
guillot directeur en petit bassin à
liberté la vidéo c'est l'ami de pascal
quoi je ne peux rien entendre dame
suisso
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hallett envers la bûche la bouche à
l'étang belle la vie mais fond des bois
tél
autour des bois la taille la vallée
oui à l'otan vers la bi michel hadji
diouf allaitent envers le corps a sonné
oh on déboule à part la balle au fond
des bois à la chanteuse
dans l'étendard la liche la douche
d'organes
ok
au fond des bois la plage il a dit au
fond des bois et les biches et celle là
[Musique]
m
dans des bois
j'ai souri
la la la
la voilà
là
la la la la
la main
[Musique]